la révolution des transports aériens est
en cours et elle va vite
la technologie des drones progresse à
toute allure et les applications
possibles sont infinis pour le meilleur
surveillance transport d'objets et
autres personnes ou pour le pire la
guerre et le terrorisme
la fermeture de l'aéroport de gatwick en
angleterre pendant plusieurs jours à
cause d'un trône qui n'a jamais été
trouvé a servi d'avertissement l'oas et
y coordonne depuis ses débuts les
mesures de sécurité qui ont trait à tous
les types d'aéronefs et maintenant aux
drones il s'agissait de trouver
d'identifier les menaces à la sécurité
par exemple
quelle doit être la longueur d'un piste
comment doit être fait le déneigement
combien d'heures peut-être pilote qui va
voler dans une seule journée
des choses comme ça une approche
universelle pour assurer la sécurité des
personnes et des biens
c'est ce que l'oaci fait depuis
exactement soixante quinze ans les
guerres ont montré le potentiel énorme
de l'aviation comment transporter
beaucoup de matériel et de personnes sur
de longues distances en un minimum de
temps
l'idée d'une organisation internationale
a été lancée à la conférence de québec
en 1943 par franklin delano roosevelt et
winston churchill et william la lma
keisuke
en novembre 1944 52 pays sans réunie à
chicago et fonde la nouvelle
organisation la place sous l'égide des
nations unies et décide qu elle siégera
à montréal le canada est déjà reconnu
comme une grande puissance aéronautique
première réunion à l'hôtel windsor à
montréal
l'oas et it any priorité numéro un la
sécurité que ce soit et nombre de clubs
peuvent voler un pilote le taille de la
photo dans votre passeport
les changes des données entre états
avant même que vous aviez un lièvre
destination vraiment eu ce que vous
pouviez imaginer en trombe en lien avec
un vol international et décider ici même
alors assis le conseil qui se réunit
dans cette salle est l'organe permanent
de l'organisation
il est composé de 36 états membres élus
tous les trois ans les grandes puissance
aérienne y sont toujours représentés les
décisions sont ratifiés par l'assemblée
des 193 pays membres qui se réunit tous
les trois ans les grands jalons des 75
ans d'histoire de l'aviation civile sont
posées ici
il a fallu encadrer toutes les grandes
percées technologiques comme les avions
réactions et les dangers comme le
terrorisme en 1969 on a compté
quatre-vingt-un détournement d'avion
dont 62 vers cuba depuis cette année
pratiquement tout le trafic aérien de la
planète et suivie en direct grâce à un
système de 66 satellites qui permettra
de raccourcir considérablement les
trajets il est aussi désormais
impossible de perdre la trace d'un avion
comme dans le cas du vol 370 de malley
jeunes quelque part dans l'océan indien
depuis 2016 la priorité est mise sur le
développement durable de l'industrie
il ya énormément de défis surtout au
niveau technologique mais nous visons
une croissance qu'à connaître à partir
de 2020 ils ne sont très fiers de nos
états membres à avoir pas venu à cette
session l'a récemment l'oaci a été
accusé de manque de transparence dans la
gestion de ses problèmes internes
elle a aussi été victime de
cyberattaques depuis 2016
vraisemblablement de la part du groupe
chinois et mes soeurs penda plusieurs
membres dans le canada ont exigé le
renforcement de ses systèmes
informatiques
plusieurs pays ont tenté de ravir à
montréal le siège de l'oaci aux vins le
mariage ne semble pas menacé et parce
qu'on est ici il y à d'autres organismes
sectoriels internationaux qui sont
présents ici à montréal
le plus connu c'est probablement iata
une association des compagnies aériennes
mais aussi l'association des pilotes et
l'association des contrôleurs aériens ya
tout un monde du secteur aérien qui
présents à montréal parce nous sommes
ici avec 700 employés la plupart des
diplomates et une centaine de
nationalités
l'oaci n'apporte pas seulement du
prestige à la ville de montréal
il contribue aussi à son économie et à
son caractère culturel international
jean michel lebrun sera du canada
montréal
[Musique]